when people ask you what happened here
tell them King James still rules the
east also tell them I'm better than
Michael Jordan is certain what plan your
generation is soft of your load
management your analytics you AAU soup
houses the gods of this game not stand
for this a reckoning is coming
[Music]
hello old friend oh boy
welcome to the mediator thank you so
delighted to be teammates again mic was
renewed you will man down without chalk
wait what twist Sir Charles he's like
the funniest guy on the ship I mean well
but luckily I'm ready to go
I've actually prepared a bit it's called
Wade's graves you see an old roof you
cannot be on the show until you've
earned your prospers Press Pass well how
do I get a press pass your audition in
audition I'm Dwayne Wade don't worry
they make it easy on X nights you just
do quick apprenticeship and then present
your findings to the other masters you
don't be reporting on an injury
apprentice to mr. mark Stein in his
investigation of an injury tour to a
horse oh I get it you're being funny
[Music]
for full mzl tears for full ACL tears
for full Achilles tears and a fool and
nectar looks like the horse will be out
indefinitely so what would happened foul
play my working theory is that Robin
Lopez mistook him for mascot I've seen
that mark before my Squire season I
think yes it's hand checking no hand
checking
don't be silly doing those banned years
ago what was this horse doing when it
got hurt most things I assume take the
support of the Raven tree and make haste
I don't want to get scooped oh um excuse
me yeah mace the wind horse ah sir
Dwayne I'm supposed to take this to the
Raven Reid do you know where that is I
do I'm going there now come poor thing
yeah tell me about it a future
hall-of-famer serving as an errand boy
to mark Stein
I meant the horse Alton definitely seems
he paid a heavy price for speaking ill
of his Airness where did you hear that
my little birds are everywhere
they were mostly around the Brawn but
some other places too if your little
birds told you anything else about this
horse I noticed a strange mark
since the horse injury my birds from
Toronto have become useless they're just
repeating the same things over and over
what kind of things
oh how nights these days are soft how
the 90s were the best how sir Jordan is
the goat boring old man stuff really
boring her could it be related to the
soul boss hmm I didn't think to make
that connection but then again I didn't
have your instincts I never played the
game you never played now everything I
learned about basketball I learned in
here
so many books all the stories records
recaps bucks calls and even memes they
all live here we are this world's memory
Dwayne without us the histories and
legends of our realm would all vanish
like James Harden in a meaningful
playoff game some say if it's nothing
here it never happened now if you'll
excuse me for one moment when I need to
grab a book but I can't come in I'm
afraid this is very sensitive
information only maesters with a press
pass can enter hello Dwayne Sir Paul
there is no more Paul there is only the
truth right now that I'm in the media I
see oh I know
and yes I am better than you I have to
go now see all right let's go
well this looks like a nice place to
have a long-form intimate conversation
about basketball
yes here is where we do our podcasts and
here we are welcome to The Raven room
this is where the media talent families
connect or some say even merge the
network of platforms you see represent
the various localities that make up the
greatest social media Dell a
never-ending conversation between
Fanning scribes and Knights you see
until very recently only those cloaked
in media Dell chains could reach all
corners of borås but no longer so what
do you have for me I have this injury
report I'd like to send out for a mr.
Stein how do I open definitely I broke
that ten minutes ago windows what about
you another story about LeBron those
were different times this is a story
about how Luca Dunwich is the next
LeBron
generations of non-fundamental windows
look looks like it's not just my Ravens
Seven Hills is going on tour on
territory but whatever it is seems red
train we've got to get the cream city I
agree oh wait my audition it's tomorrow
night's don't worry I'll get us there in
no time
for I am as fast as the inland I'll rip
your bloody antlers off Bobby come on
brother it's supposed to be play
wrestling you know this bastard tricked
me deciding a giant fake contract
I asked that you be stormy day gift of
wrench please Jesus Shuttlesworth be
honest come quickly or being attacked is
some sort of scheduling mistake I didn't
think there was a battle today
we just look there's Yanis
this generation is soft Jordan is the
goat LeBron is weak
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]